[Applause]
every photo is like a drive-by
I have probably from 200 times in south
Louisiana 2050 on the website I was
saying this belt usually used on
treadmills the pipe to the carburetor is
some sort of vacuum cleaner assembly I
[Music]
first saw south Louisiana from the air
flying in and out of New Orleans on
commercial flights
it's an infinitely complex ecosystem
what I really wanted to do is just go up
in the air and explore
okay so were you thinking sailed to the
same campsite or somewhere else so that
you get closer to the next Island I kind
of want to fly to this other Island
that's gonna be four miles like six
miles eight miles
I didn't write my mom's texting I was
always intrigued by the barrier islands
it's an interesting landscape that I
wanted to fly in photograph
[Music]
we bought this sailboat in an effort to
use less gasoline people used to use
this kind of hundred years ago in
Louisiana for oystering and fishing so
we thought it would be a smart move to
use that to get around out here
[Music]
in an ideal world my paramotor wouldn't
burn in gasoline but this is the most
efficient way for me to get up in the
air and fly around until I stop flying
around and just sail the rest of my life
[Music]
we should go wandering around and look
for dead things on the beach tonight is
pushes Grill and beans and a can of
green beans and it should be delicious
my neighbor is a scrapper and scraps
aluminum and often fines and food the
food that he doesn't want he gives to me
so I've got a whole bag of canned food
over here
[Music]
these barrier islands are eroding at
rates of something like up to 60 feet
per year
[Music]
when you look at the maps it's just a
thin beach line but in reality you can
see where they've been rebuilding the
beaches all throughout this area to try
to preserve this bit of life for a
little longer
[Music]
the reason I started working on this
project was essentially environmental
communication I think these images can
be used by the scientific community to
kind of raise awareness about how this
landscape works great flight the other
day that was cool a lot of my work has
been down here for me as a scientist I
very closely linked education and
research part of research is to educate
people I collaborate with some folks
from NASA and they can calculate a
vegetation index how much vegetation is
there but one of the problems with
satellites is you don't really know
exactly what they're looking at whether
it's algae or whether it's marsh grasses
yeah I mean from 50 feet up you can tell
what type of vegetation it is exactly
and right in a way that would be much
more precise than you could get from an
airplane south Louisiana feels like
you're in some kind of remote wilderness
until you get up in the air
and then you can see that you're just
surrounded by miles and miles of oyster
Lisa's shrimpers trawling the horizon is
just dotted with endless oil rigs
everything is exploited in one way or
another
[Music]
[Applause]
everywhere you look you see these oil
and gas pipeline canals those canals are
what allowed saltwater intrusion to
penetrate so far north and then killed
the vegetation which was holding the
soil in place and then that's what
really triggered most of the wetland
loss
[Music]
why brother
[Music]
deepest
I've met old people down in this area
that tell me this used to be meta or
they grazed cattle and now it's just
open water with the edges of the canals
remaining
[Music]
when I started this project that had in
my mind a handful of images that would
tell the story of wetland loss and then
experiencing this place drew me in and
kept me exploring
it's really become a process and going
out and looking for like magic
[Music]
the Sun sing the song so sue them star
too
cream
[Applause]
[Music]
I Love New Orleans but try to be
realistic about living here you know one
major hurricane without that protection
of the wetlands we will all be finding a
new place to live
[Music]
[Music]
there is so much value in this ecosystem
hopefully I'm able to capture a little
bit of that with my photographs and kind
of make people think about this place a
little more
[Music]
when I'm flying I often have this
feeling of overwhelming beauty which is
like deep sadness for what's been lost
to feelings at the same time constantly
[Music]
the time
he's weaving
it's hard
see
[Music]
[Music]